I'm loop hours i'm one of the historians
here at Colonial Williamsburg and I'm
pleased to introduce to you today joanne
freeman assistant professor of history
at Yale she received her PhD at the
University of Virginia and she's no
stranger around here at Colonial
Williamsburg having spoken in this room
several times now including at a waves
Berg Institute about Jefferson and the
election of 1800 this time last year I
believe dr. Freeman's book affairs of
Honor national politics in the New
Republic published by the Yale
University Press just this year has
received enthusiastic notices reviewers
have used such adjectives as vivid
incisive dynamic original impeccable I
wholeheartedly agree Joanne actually
this work is the capstone of a trend
back toward imaginative political
history and what makes this trend so
exciting for me is that it's early
America that is providing the issues and
the questions and the people for this
whole return to political history and
it's of course glad to see this coming
I'm glad to see this coming out of this
time period Williamsburg's period and to
see such talented people as dr. Freeman
turning their efforts toward the writing
of this political history now as you
probably noticed today's presentation is
being taped by c-span to find out when
it will be broadcast fire up your
computer and go to book TV dot org and
they will let you know when this will be
broadcast but I can think of few things
more fitting than a discussion of
politics and the importance of honor and
behavior on this day after election day
so please welcome Joanne be Friedman
thanks very much what I'd like to talk
about today is politics in the first
decade of the national government right
after the Constitution kicked in when
national politicians were really
figuring out how this new experimental
government was really going to work now
typically when we look back to this time
period we imagine the founders as
statesmen capital s engaged in lofty
political arguments high above the Nitty
Gritty of politics we don't tend to
think of the founders as politicians but
the fact remains that the founders were
politicians participating in the dirty
world of hands on politics why don't we
notice this well in part it's because
we've been defining early American
politics according to 20th century terms
according to our Terms looking for
things like party systems because
politics today is oriented around a
two-party system we tend to look for its
origins in the founding period but in
looking for a party system to the
exclusion of everything else we've been
evaluating early American politics
according to its deficiencies by how it
compares with present-day politics
instead of looking at it as a system in
its own right with its own special logic
now when we examine the periods politics
from a participants perspective we
discover a world very different from our
own America's first national politicians
had a distinctive understanding of their
world and their placed within it as
gentlemen and as leaders to understand
the logic of their politics we first
have to understand this mental framework
that shaped their world now for me the
most important window into this alien
world is the private correspondence of
national politicians which I always
refer to my Yale students as dead
people's mail
because in the phrasing and the tone and
the content of their letters politicians
really offer invaluable clues about the
logic of their thoughts and feelings and
I want to give an example of one kind of
letter that really offers this kind of
insight and in fact it's actually one of
the letters that really began my book as
a whole and it's a letter that was
written by James Monroe to his friend
James Madison in 1798 and as Monroe
explained in this letter he needed
advice vice president John Adams had
insulted Monroe in a very public big
lecture when Rose was horrified at this
but he wasn't quite sure how to respond
and so he was asking for Madison's
advice and Monroe wrote in this letter
he couldn't ignore the insult as he put
it not to notice it may with many leave
an unfavorable impression against me his
next option was well maybe I can respond
personally with a challenge to a duel
but he decided he couldn't do this
because with impeccable logic he said
Adams is an old man and the president I
love this letter um maybe he could write
a pamphlet he thought but he'd written a
pamphlet in the relatively recent past
and this didn't seem to stop Adams from
insulting him so here you can see Monroe
and he's literally ticking off a list of
strategies he's making a political
decision among clearly defined options
with different rules and implications
really a set of different political
weapons that clearly he has in his head
and he's sifting through them to try and
figure out how to respond to this moment
of political Kombat and the same group
of weapons appears again and again and
again throughout all of the
correspondence of the period now when we
reconstruct all of the shoulds and
should not that run beneath the surface
of these letters we discover that the
founders were guided in their public
lives by two basic forces number one the
code of honor and number two the idea of
republicanism and I'll get back to that
one in a couple of minutes that'll start
with honor culture now this whole idea
of honor culture in the way that it was
understood in early America is
really particularly alien to us now as
modern onlookers but it really was the
central organizing force of political
Kombat in the early republic ranked
reputation and honor were a vital
concern to any gentlemen of the early
republic a man without honor was really
no man at all and for public figures
whose careers rested on their
reputations such things had extreme
importance reputation took on even more
importance in the very personal world of
early national politics in the first
years of its existence in this period
before there were real defined national
political parties so in essence there
were no predictable fighting teams on
the national stage it was difficult if
not impossible to predict how people
would vote this was a politics of
shifting coalition's and unknown
loyalties where an ally could become an
enemy at the drop of a hat a man's
reputation his status his friends and
enemies thus had great importance
because there were means of determining
his politics given the dire importance
of reputation a character attack could
inflict deadly damage to a politician's
life and career and thus the importance
of the code of honor where insults could
have such grave consequences there had
to be clearly defined rules and
standards to prevent accidental insults
so the code of honor set out clear
standards of conduct certain words to
avoid certain actions to avoid and when
a line was crossed and honor was
offended the code of honor offered a
regulated way of settling the dispute
hopefully with negotiations but
sometimes with gun play on a dueling
ground for example there were a number
of what i always call alarm bell words
that you could never use in reference to
another gentleman and these words
largely consisted of the words liar
coward Rascal and scoundrel which sort
of have lost their zing in the modern
world I think but my personal favorite
alarm bell world word is puppy never
call the gentleman a puppy and these
were really fighting words
and anyone who hurled one of these words
at an opponent was almost inviting a
duel and when you look at records from
the period and you see one of these
moments which you can watch like in
congressional debate when things are
moving in a bad direction and people can
see one of these words is on the tip of
someone's tongue the hushed anticipation
that you can see in these accounts these
eyewitness accounts is really amazing to
see faces Blanche people go still
background noise stops and everyone
turns to look at the face of the accuser
and his victim to see exactly how that
moment is going to play out for example
let's look at a 1797 conversation
between Alexander Hamilton and actually
poor James Monroe again and conversation
is a very nice way of putting this as
you'll see in that year Hamilton in
Monroe became involved in a controversy
Hamilton believed that Monroe had leaked
to the newspapers reports about a recent
adulterous affair that Hamilton had had
and Hamilton had indeed had the
adulterous affair and ultimately would
go on to write a tell-all pamphlet in
which he confessed in great detail what
happened in this adulterous affair and
his argument essentially was yes I'm an
adulterer but I'm a good leader in
public life so support me exactly i'll
make no comment on that argument at all
um so anyway he's outraged that this
news has been leaked so he took a friend
and he went to James Monroe's house to
demand an explanation and luckily Monroe
had a friend present who recorded this
entire conversation now Hamilton in
Monroe hated each other so things didn't
start out very well after some terse
conversation and you can just see in the
account of this conversation Hamilton is
getting red faced Monroe is getting I
see Hamilton finally just came out and
accused Monroe of leaking the
information and when Monroe denied this
halton said and his word choice is
really key here this as your
representation is totally false now he's
being really careful with his words
because of course what he is saying to
Monroe without quite saying it is you're
a liar
and even without saying that alarm bell
word what happened at this woman is
really fascinating because both Monroe
and Hamilton knew instantly that a line
had been crossed and as soon as the
words came out of Hamilton's mouth both
men jumped to their feet now they
literally were involved in an affair of
Honor and they both knew it so Monroe
was responded first by taking Hamilton's
dare and pushing it one step further
saying do you say I represented falsely
you are a scoundrel matching Hamilton's
insult with one of his own hamilton
responded as any man of honor would
saying i will meet you like a gentleman
which means literally I'm ready to do
when you are and monroe replied I am
ready get your pistols at which point
the friends of the two men thrust
themselves between them pull them apart
and quieted them down so that they
didn't run out and immediately begin
shooting at each other now this dispute
never made it to the dueling ground and
it's important to note that the vast
majority of Honor disputes never did
it's one of the many things that
actually really surprised me when I
began researching my book the point of
an affair of Honor was to demonstrate
your willingness to die for your honor
but not necessarily to engage in gunplay
so it was entirely possible to redeem
your honor during negotiations by
declaring your willingness to duel and
then reaching some kind of a compromise
and never ending up on a dueling ground
so in a sense negotiations were even
more important than the duel itself and
so there were endless formal rules and
regulations for this negotiating process
when you realize that negotiations like
this were actually formal affairs of
Honor you discover that honor disputes
were surprisingly common in early
America for example few people know that
Alexander Hamilton was involved in ten
affairs of Honor before his 1804 duel
with Aaron Burr 10 times he had
negotiated an honor dispute though on
those occasions as in the one I've just
described with James Monroe there wasn't
they sort of says he tap-danced around
for a while wrote letters back and forth
and ultimately nothing happened in the
case of the dispute with Monroe they
wrote letters to each other for months
six six months and a chelator said
essentially
same thing which is I'm ready to fight
when you are but neither one wanted to
be the guy to issue the challenge and so
nothing ever happened and finally they
both sort of said to themselves well I
came out on top and it just ended so
there was no real formal resolution so
an affair of Honor clearly is a way of
grappling with the dishonor of down and
dirty politics disgrace disaster or even
defeat sometimes demand in such an
extreme response the ever embattled
Alexander Hamilton showed this logic in
action in 1795 in July of that year
there was a loud public demonstration
against the Jay Treaty which many of his
opponents the Republicans saw as a
complete surrender to the British the
Republican protest meeting was to start
at noon and at the stroke of twelve
Hamilton trying to take complete control
of the situation surrounded by a few of
his high-ranking Federalist friends
climbed up onto a stoop and tried to
take control of this whole demonstration
by addressing the audience only to be
silenced by what one newspaper described
as kissing's coughing's and hooting
'he's when he offered to explain the
treaty the crowd yelled back that
newspaper accounts enabled them to
consider it for themselves thank you
very much when he responded by telling
the crowd that they had no
constitutional right to give an opinion
on the treaty they broke into an uproar
not a good advisable tack in front of a
mob and suddenly someone threw a rock
striking Hamilton in the head so calling
out for the Friends of order to follow
him he marched off with a small body of
Federalists defeated frustrated and
angry he soon encountered a loud public
argument between a federalist and
Republican when he tried to break it up
the Republican essentially said to him
why do I need to listen to you which was
yet another humiliation and so Hamilton
did what many a gentleman would have
done in this case he challenged the man
to a duel seething he continued down the
street only to encounter another
argument which drove him into an
absolute passion during which he
allegedly waved his fist in
the air and offered to fight the whole
detestable faction one by one at which
point a Republican step forward to
accept the challenge and offered to meet
Hamilton with pistols in half an hour
wherever he pleased explaining that he
already had one duel pending halton
swore when that one's done you'll get
your do so now that's really incredible
to duel challenges within hours
asserting his right to guide the people
as their superior Hamilton had been met
by resentment resistance disrespect and
rocks mortified by this kind of a slap
at his status he turned to the code of
honor to reaffirm his reputation in his
membership among the ruling elite and in
fact one of the many things that
surprised me in writing the book was um
in these cases he does sort of have
seemed to have lost his temper but
actually in many cases and many of the
duels that I was studying many
politicians were deliberately provoking
them to redeem their names and
specifically after an election very
often the loser of an election or one of
his friends would provoke the winner or
one of his friends into a duel to sort
of redeem himself from the disgrace of
having lost the election so in a sense
dishonored by a democratic election
politicians sometimes turn to this
aristocratic code of honor to sort of
make amends and prove that they belonged
among the elite this new understanding
of political dueling casts the 1804 duel
between hamilton and aaron burr in an
entirely new light that year Aaron burrs
political career was in trouble although
he was Jefferson's vice president he was
entirely distrusted by Jefferson who
cast him aside after his first term so
turning to his home state of New York
burr decided to run for governor only to
lose helped along by Hamilton's active
opposition this was a humiliating loss
for burr because first he'd been ousted
from the vice presidency now he'd been
publicly declared not good enough to be
governor and not surprisingly he began
to feel desperate to prove himself a
deserving political leader especially to
his supporters who were beginning to
doubt him
why cling tuber is a leader if he could
offer no patronage no power no influence
and some of his supporters actually said
this quite literally as one put it burr
had to fight back for if he tain ly sat
down in silence what must have been the
feelings of his friends they must have
considered him as a man not possessing
sufficient firmness to defend his own
character and consequently unworthy of
their support so really to prove himself
a political leader burr had to do
something to redeem his reputation and
he was in this frame of mind when a
friend put a newspaper clipping in his
hand that suggested that Hamilton had
said something quote despicable about
burr now it's important to note at this
point that burr was not thinking I must
slaughter Hamilton which is sort of the
way people tend to depict bird during
this duel he was just a murderous fiend
out to kill rather he was thinking I've
been humiliated my political career is
dying I have to prove my worth and now
here in my hand is authentic evidence of
someone attacking my honor and better
yet it's evidence of Hamilton attacking
me and he's been attacking me for 15
years at this point so for burr
defending his honor felt necessary at
this point it made sense to him and
actually Halton specific insult made
little difference and in fact there
never was a more specific insult
indicated than Hamilton said something
Despicable about burr burr was just
looking for a way to redeem his name and
this actually provides the answer to one
mystery that surrounds the burr Hamilton
duel what was the mysterious despicable
thing that Hamilton said the caused
birth to challenge him now people have
come up with all kinds of alternatives
to answering that question and the most
popular one is the Hamilton accused burr
of incest of sleeping with his own
daughter and that actually comes from
gore Vidal from his novel burr but the
fact is that as with many deliberately
provoked duels the precise insult was
less important than burst chance to
redeem his honor there actually was no
specific insult there was a general
insult that burr seized upon to clear
his name sober sent Hamilton a
ritualized letter
inquiring about Hamilton's alleged
insult and demanding a response to
Hamilton clearly here was a threat but
Hamilton was puzzled because burr said
only that Hamilton had uttered something
Despicable about him and how could
Hamilton explain or defend something
that seemed that vague Hamilton's
response to this letter was actually
most unfortunate and it really shows how
conflicted he was he was torn between
his feeling of his need to face first
challenge and his real desire to avoid
fighting a duel and in fact while
they're negotiating the duel Hamilton
acknowledges that once before they had
almost dueled and Hamilton had backed
out versus twice before they hit almost
dueled in Hamilton had found a way out
so this is in burrs is at least the
third time that they've come near to
fighting so Hamilton is responding yet
again and he's trying to find a way out
of the predicament again this time so he
begins his letter with this long
tortured argument about the meaning of
the word despicable asking essentially
well what does despicable mean between
gentlemen in any way is despicable that
bad I don't know I don't think it's so
bad well tuber Hamilton's argument
sounded like any evasive insulting
grammar lesson Hamilton then concluded
his letter with a burst of bluster to
show that he was not afraid to duel if
he had to he wrote that he would not be
held responsible for hearsay and that he
was willing to face the consequences for
his actions a statement that tuber
seemed like an arrogant dare needless to
say burrs response to Hamilton's letter
was quick and sharp he said that
Hamilton's letter revealed quote nothing
of that sincerity and delicacy which you
profess to value saying in other words
Hamilton was behaving like no gentleman
this is a highly offensive insult that
Hamilton couldn't ignore so now Hamilton
felt insulted and couldn't back down and
burr felt insulted and more insistent on
fighting and you can begin to see how
things were spiraling down from this
point on and though Halden eventually
offered something of an explanation
stating that he didn't whatever he said
he's sure he didn't mean it
in a personal kind of way by that point
burr was so insulted that he really felt
that nothing but a trip to the dueling
ground could redeem his honor so bird
did what any grievously dishonor
gentleman would have done he demanded an
apology from Hamilton that was so
humiliating that it would force Hamilton
to fight there was no way that Hamilton
could give this apology burr insisted
that Hamilton apologized for everything
that he had ever said that was
derogatory about birds private character
from throughout their entire 15-year
rivalry and asber expected hamilton
could not agree to this and burr then
formally challenged him to a duel and it
was a challenge that Halton accepted now
house in later explained his actions in
a final statement that he wrote the
night before the duel and he intended it
to be made public only in the event of
his death and this document actually is
the focus of one of the chapters a
chapter on dueling in affairs of honor
and I should say it's one of those
documents that it's not as though it's
been a secret you know it's been
published for very long time but no one
ever read it really closely before and
no one thus ever seems to have noticed
that Hamilton was essentially saying in
this statement here is why I'm dueling
let me explain it to you so for me
trying to understand why people duel
this was this wonderful document that I
was so happy existed but I actually was
stunning to me that no one who quite
read it that way before so in this
statement Hamilton acknowledged first
all of the reasons why he didn't want a
duel his family his debts his religious
scruples and his basic desire to live he
also explained why he felt compelled to
fight he had seriously insulted burr
over the course of their 15-year rivalry
he believed what he had said so it
wasn't as though he could apologize for
it particularly since burr had insulted
Hamilton during their negotiations most
fundamental of all he felt that as he
put it all the considerations which
constitute what men of the world to
nominate honor impressed on me as I
thought a peculiar necessity not to
decline the call the ability to be in
future useful in those crises of our
public affairs which seemed likely to
happen would probably be
separable from a conformity with public
prejudice in this particular which is a
long way of saying but Hamilton really
expected a future crisis and actually he
expected a future civil war and in his
mind if he didn't seem like a leader if
he didn't defend his honor he would be
dishonored and then he would be cast off
and useless at that moment of crisis
when he would really want to step
forward so in essence Hamilton like fur
was dueling to prove himself a worthy
political leader people who study the
burr Hamilton duel tend to blame it on
irrational emotion claiming that burr
was a murderous fiend out to kill
Hamilton and that Hamilton was depressed
and had a death wish in effect he was
committing suicide by duel but the two
men's decisions were not irrational or
purely emotional clearly their their
reasoning their way according to some
kind of a course of logic so the logic
of political Kombat was grounded on the
code of honor and in fact as I found by
looking at hundreds and hundreds of
letters politicians had a remarkably
precise understanding of an entire code
of political Kombat a set of rules and
standards that enable them to attack
reputations or defend their own by using
different weapons and as I suggested
with the 1798 James Monroe letter to
James Madison politicians understood
that certain insults demanded a certain
kind of defense and both the insults and
their defense were grounded on the code
of honor some of these political weapons
are recognizable to us today and for
example we wouldn't be surprised today
by the political use of pamphlets or
newspaper essays or personal letters
other political weapons like these
deliberately provoked duels that I've
just mentioned have escaped our notice
though their impact was as great if not
greater political gossip is another
unusual and unexpected political weapon
deployed during this period governed by
real rules and standards and politicians
I've actually had words for it they
would describe themselves as collecting
or dropping these pieces of information
or bits of gossip and so they would
collect or drop gossip and elaborate
again their phrase whisper campaigns
designed to destroy an opponent's
reputation or bolster their own which
brings us to
thomas jefferson throughout his entire
political career Jefferson habitually
recorded interesting dinner table
conversations or small talk about his
enemies or in other words gossip on
little bits of paper actually sometimes
even at the table apparently he'd be
scribbling in one case he wrote on a
piece of paper this written at the
moment Helton left the room so there's
sort of eyewitness little memos about
what he's hearing at any given moment
and he carefully preserved all these
bits of paper for future use because
there was no telling when that kind of
information might be useful against an
enemy in his old age he put these bits
of paper together into three bound
volumes along with some of his letters
and deposited them in his papers to be
discovered after his death intending
them he wrote actually an introduction
to the volumes and tending them to be a
history of the real truth of the periods
politics and a later editor of his
papers dubbed this collection of gossip
the annus which is latin for Table Talk
and the annus actually also at the
center of one of the chapters in affairs
of Honor now again just like with
Hamilton's apologia the night before the
duel many historians have used the adas
over the years but none have ever really
realized exactly what it is it's a
gossip blog it's a collection of
Republican gossip about Federalists not
surprisingly most of it about Alexander
Hamilton now not only is its mere
existence fascinating but in these
memoranda you can see Jefferson himself
collecting gossip researching it
dropping it in key places with key
people think of all the energy that he
was expending on political gossip he had
cultivated it recorded it preserved it
for decades and then preserved it to for
posterity as the truth an understanding
of this kind of a political weapon
reveals the political dimension not only
of Thomas Jefferson but also of George
Washington a man whom historians often
depicted as more of a symbol than a
political player for example in 1791
Washington was informed that a foreign
visitor named count andreani was writing
nasty letters to friends in Europe
insulting Thomas Jefferson and John
Adams and ridiculing this new American
government
Washington's response was brutally
effective he showed one of and rihanna's
letters to some key selected friends
confident that they would gossip about
this letter to others and within days
andreani was so hated that as he put it
he was forced to decamp he actually had
to flee the city and here you see the
power of political gossip and the
political skill of George Washington so
there we've gotten something of an
overview of the politics of honor and
reputation and some idea about some of
its political weapons now I want to just
briefly look at the second shaping force
of early national politics this idea of
republicanism with a small are now as
good Republicans americans consider
themselves a breed apart from what they
deemed corrupt europeans they believed
that this new american nation which was
a republican nation was everything that
its european counterparts were not
America was egalitarian democratic
representative straightforward and
virtuous and spirit public-minded in
practice and Republican leaders were
supposedly exceptional as well a natural
elite of the talented and worthy who
lived modestly dressed practically and
behaved forthrightly in a spirit of
accommodation yet though most public men
agreed upon this kind of generality
things like simplicity and virtue were
relative terms they were meaningful in
comparison with European luxury and
corruption but it's not as though you
can define simplicity or define virtue
and sort of enacted in America so there
are a lot of questions that came up and
they're actually really practical
down-to-earth questions that were
important because they were literally
creating a government and it was a new
kind of government and they were trying
to figure out not only how to operate it
but what's the style of a republican
government how does it appear how do we
behave what does a Republican leader
look like and so literally in their
correspondence they're debating things
like how does a Republican politician
dress how much finery is too much should
a Republican politician own a carriage
and if so how many horses seemed
excessive these were very real questions
to national politicians who are really
we're
read about national character this new
kind of national character in this new
kind of government and they were
questions that were important enough to
provoke the criticism and comments of
gentleman throughout the nation for
example in 1789 one of President George
Washington's friends congratulated him
on his decision to walk in the street
every day Carly every day at two o'clock
George Washington walked around the
block and did not ride in a carriage and
everyone noticed this and he got fan
mail for walking in the street around
the block two o'clock every day this was
very Republican of him this same friend
then went on to criticize vice president
John Adams for his frequent use of a
carriage and gasped six courses a
Washington defended Adams by reporting
that no no we actually used for horses
which is a much more Republican number
than six atoms himself defensively
remarked and somewhat sarcastically
remarked that I walk a league in the
streets every day which is more than
every other member of Congress ever did
so that in this respect I am undoubtedly
the most virtuous man anywhere to be
found so these ambiguities of
republicanism this is this idea about
what is simple or what is virtuous what
is Republican and the importance of
these things to the success or failure
of the American experiment in government
were immediate and ever-present these
ideas in the lives of politicians
shaping even the most seemingly trivial
of decisions for example confusion about
republicanism literally stopped
Pennsylvania senator William of clay
dead in his tracks during a 1791 dinner
party I maclise a wonderful character he
was a senator in the first Congress he
wrote this amazing diary in which he
recorded everything he recorded his
dreams he recorded what people were
snacking on as they sat in their desk
and Congress he reported what he heard
people whispering like he heard someone
say John Adams needs his wig dressed
this went into his diary so it's a
wonderful wonderful document and one
thing that the diary reveals is that he
just adored George Washington he so
revered him that when he was in the same
room as George Washington he's just he
didn't know what to say he would flush
he would you know stumble around he was
always completely sort of out of sorts
when he was around what he called the
first
man in the United States so in his diary
he in 1791 he described going to this
dinner party and he walks into the room
of course who was at the door but
President Washington so already he's a
little nonplussed by this so he sort of
did what he considered early clumsy
bowel and then he began to walk across
the room he said in his diary he spotted
some empty seats across the room next to
some New Englanders and he's even though
they're New Englanders he said he went
to go and sit by them anyway New
Englanders had a reputation for not
being really socially adept in this time
period but as he head off towards these
seats out of the corner of his eye he
saw Washington gesture for him to sit
next to him and this entirely through
McClay into confusion and he literally
stopped dead in his tracks on the floor
of this room and thought to himself what
would a good Republican do now he wanted
to turn around and accept the honor what
an honor but a good Republican should
not be too deferential to the president
who should not seem to be like a king in
any way and if Washington was treated
like a king he might become one and so
McClay actually reassuring himself that
he was acting in the nation's best
interest walked away from Washington did
not accept the seat and went and SAT
across the room was sort of torn that he
couldn't accept the honor but very
virtuously described in his diary that
night that he'd done this great
patriotic act by not treating Washington
like a king and refusing this great
compliment so obviously the mandates of
republicanism affected politics on an
everyday basis a Republican politician
was supposed to be entirely accountable
to the American people his activities
open to the vigilant eye of the voting
public secret bargaining and private
negotiations were highly suspect
associated with the corruption and
intrigue of old world politics yet they
were also necessary in the practical
business of politics so how could a
Republican politician politic social
events seem to solve this problem
political interaction at a social event
was public enough to avoid charges of
intrigue but private enough to allow
negotiations through Table Talk and
informal asides social events were a
nebulous middle ground that allowed
politicking without violating political
Prince
ables and foreign visitors actually
noticed this as something that seemed to
them distinctly American as one French
Minister advised one of his countrymen
among American politicians it is after
dinner that one relaxes discusses
matters and it is during the toasts that
confidence and persuasion can slip in
your minister could do nothing here did
he not often have congressman at his
dinner table the political nature of
social events reveals the political role
of elite women because women were seated
at dinner tables alongside their
husbands and they were just as skilled
at collecting or dropping useful bits of
information and Abigail Adams
particularly was very adept at such
politicking and I found in her papers
actually really remarkable
transcriptions of entire dinner
conversations written almost as a script
and she particularly likes sitting next
to Thomas Jefferson and then sort of
clear and her transcriptionstar goading
him and he was clearly sort of
discomforted by this so she has all of
these wonderful accounts of
conversations where she's trying to get
him to confess things that clearly he
doesn't want to confess and she's
clearly kind of enjoying herself while
doing it mrs. a and she would give her
comment mr. J and give his comment
Martha Washington on the other hand was
not as willing to be a politician aware
of how desperately President Washington
wanted to discern public opinion of his
presidency one of his secretary
suggested using his wife as a spy or as
the secretary put it Martha's serious
and benevolent countenance would not
suffer a person to hide a thing from her
they'll never suspect that she's
collecting information but Martha
Washington was less than thrilled at the
prospect this did not happen an
understanding of the political
importance of dinner parties also
reveals Jefferson's real skill as a
politician because he was an absolute
master of dinner table politicking and
one Federalist even came up with a name
for Jefferson's political technique
dubbing it Jefferson's epicurean
artifices
and his political memoranda his gossip
blog shows this in action so let's look
a little bit more closely at one of
Jefferson's dinner parties on january
second 1792 Jefferson invited
representatives Thomas fit Simon's of
Pennsylvania amass a learning of
Connecticut and Elbridge Gerry of
Massachusetts to dinner along with
several other guests after everyone but
these three representatives had left the
conversation magically turned to the
subject of congressional references to
cabinet members for advice Jefferson and
his friends considered this kind of
congressional reference the source of
Hamilton's influence and success
Congress would ask Hamilton for advice
boy did Hamilton give advice Hamilton
would essentially write legislation and
in this way he was getting a lot of
influence over Congress so here we have
a dinner party where the conversation
has magically turned to this key point
so the men talked for time and at the
end of the evening Jefferson recorded in
a memorandum that Gary and fit Simon's
were clearly opposed to such references
two days later when the house referred a
question to the secretary of the
Treasury Hamilton Jefferson noted with
some satisfaction on that same slip of
paper Gary and Fitzsimmons opposed it
two weeks later Fitz Simon's again
opposed a reference to Hamilton and
Jefferson again on that same slip of
paper wrote that fact down finally six
weeks later on March 7th Republicans in
Congress broached the issue in earnest
arguing that the house was capable of
doing its own business without referring
matters to Hamilton and after an
animated debate Hamilton supporters
prevailed Gary changed sides Jefferson
wrote on that same piece of paper try to
explain how it could possibly be that
hamilton won over him in this basic
congressional issue but clearly you can
see how his innocent dinner party was in
truth a deliberate attempt to test and
reinforce potential supporters in the
house the start of a campaign against
Hamilton's influence documented in
Jefferson's detailed memorandum
Jefferson was simply talking with
friends but he was also engaged in a
political discussion criticizing
Hamilton's influence over the
legislature a discussion aimed at
encouraging three representatives to
vote along properly Republican lines
compare Jefferson's
masterfully indirect dinner with a
similar dinner orchestrated by Hamilton
I wish to have the advantage of a
conversation with you alanson wrote to
Robert Morris in November 1790 if you
will name a day for taking a family
dinner with me I shall think of the best
arrangements the chief subjects will be
additional funds for the public debt and
the bank now it is important to note
that dinner table politicking was not
reserved to Thomas Jefferson but not
everyone was as skilled at passively
directing such dinners for political
purposes this was really Jefferson's
forte even those who distrusted him
found themselves drawn to him at his
dinner table New Hampshire senator
William plumber who greatly distressed
at Jefferson was eventually won over by
such means on one occasion plumber noted
and he's another senator who has an
amazing diary so he noted in his diary
that on Jeffersons dinner table among
the eight different types of wine and II
as he put a great variety of pies fruits
and nuts were two bottles of water from
the Mississippi River and a piece of the
Mammoth's cheese now I have to pause at
this point because of the mammoth cheese
this is essentially my favorite goofy
thing from this time period the mammoth
cheese was an enormous 1,200 pound four
foot long wheel of cheese that some
citizens of Massachusetts made and
presented to Jefferson during his
inauguration in 1801 and the mammoth
cheese was amazingly famous in the time
period there was poetry written about
the mammoth cheese I've seen at the
Library of Congress and ode to the great
cheese which someone engraved this is
very serious engraving of the cheese on
this ode to the great cheese and
apparently Jefferson had public viewings
of the cheese on New Year's Day
so they're on Jeffersons table is water
from the Mississippi River and a piece
of the mammoth cheese so in other words
the stage was literally set to woo
guests with an evening of stimulating
conversation focused around topics of
interest the Mississippi River the
mammoth cheese topics that by chance
show Jefferson in a particularly good
light now I should note also that
William plumber that dinner guests he
ate some of the cheese in 1805 which is
four years after Jefferson received the
mammoth cheese and plumber wrote in his
diary very diplomatically it was far
from being very good so clearly when you
understand the importance of
republicanism and you understand the
political importance of honor and
reputation you begin to understand the
emotional reality of being a national
politician during America's founding the
knee-jerk sense of panic that they had
the rampant suspicions the high passions
and shrill accusations were not
irrational they were a natural product
of a politics of reputation that blended
personal identity public office and
political experimentation in a dangerous
brew politicians were learning how to
conduct national politics one decision
at a time now of course logical
decisions can be bad decisions and one
can make rational choices for all the
wrong reasons or reason one's way into
the wrong path honorbound politicians
were not always honorable and this is
precisely the point too often the
founders are praised to the skies as
saintly deities of governance or
condemned as self-interested elitists
who cared for money and power above all
else in reality they were something of
both they sincerely wanted to create a
great nation grounded on popular will
and the rights of man they were also
obsessively concerned with their
interests careers reputations and
pocketbooks practicing down and dirty
politics in their efforts to get ahead
this is a distinction that makes a
difference if the founding generation
were abandoned angels American politics
has been in a state of free fall ever
since if they were a little more than
greedy power
others there's little hope that America
can rise to be much more however as real
people who struggle with a difficult
task sometimes inspire too high purpose
other times feeding their meanest
appetites they extend to posterity the
gift of hope if these fallible very
human people could accomplish great
things perhaps future generations can do
so as well it is the logic that inspired
their greatest hopes for the future the
ultimate message that they hope to
impart thank you very much
there are folks coming around with
microphones if you have questions dr.
Freeman has agreed to answer a couple
questions and there are of course copies
of the book available for sale in the
gift shop and shortly we will begin the
book signing there just between here and
the shop if you have a question raise
your hand and one of the folks will
bring the microphone to you yes down
here in front from all I've read did
anybody besides George Washington like
Alexander hammer for housing he did have
friends um he was a difficult difficult
person and the fact that matter is you
know Jefferson was someone who clearly
had friends who were his equal Hamilton
was not someone who was easy to get
along with and he had friends but they
were mostly people who clearly he
considered sort of a rung beneath him
and and they were willing to play that
kind of a role so you know he was
arrogant he was aggressive he didn't
like to listen to anything anyone had to
say he was always sure that he was right
without question and even Washington you
know sometimes people would say to
Washington you know what do you see in
this guy you know he is so ambitious and
Washington would say well yes he's
ambitious but it's a laudable kind of
ambition you know it's the kind of
ambition that really makes him try to
achieve great things and because of that
he's a valuable person he's a good
person so he apparently was actually
socially apparently he was kind of a
popular guy and as a matter of fact he
too popular guy their stories about
Hamilton going to social events and
granted John Adams really really hated
Alexander Hamilton as did so many others
so you can't entirely trust John Adams
as gossip but John Adams did once
described watching Hamilton enter a
party and describing how Hamilton
essentially scoped the horizon for the
women in the room to decide on his
targets for that evening
how true that is I don't know but um
clearly he was someone who not quite as
much as Aaron Burr but someone who
enjoyed a good time you one notch below
Aaron Burr and enjoying a good time
isn't it the case that Hamilton's son
also died in a duel and Hamilton always
felt that maybe he should have prevented
it yeah it's actually it's an amazing
story he has he had a son it's Philip
his oldest son was 19 years old in 1801
and that year july 4th there had been a
Republican talk and the fellow giving
the talk his name was iker had insulted
Hamilton during the course of his July
4th corasian so a couple months later
Hamilton's son was at the theater and I
think he was sitting behind eager who
was with ladies and he had the gall he
and a friend to deliberately say nasty
things about eager and trying to sort of
get back at him for saying bad things
about his father and eager you know this
was in front of ladies not only was it
humiliating but in front of ladies so
I'm eager got upset and there was a
confrontation and eager ended up
challenging both phillip hamilton and
his friend to duels and in a sense the
saddest part of the story is that philip
then went to his father and said now
what do i do dad here i am in this
situation and by that point i think its
nine maybe eight or nine maybe eight
times there been eight occasions on that
point already at which Hamilton had been
involved in some kind of an affair of
Honor but never had he gone to the
dueling ground and clearly he assumed
that this was going to be a case like
all those other cases he'd been involved
in and so what he said to his son was
number one you can't apologize cuz
apparently Iker had collard Phillip and
given him a good shake in the lobby of
the theater so Hamilton said well you've
been physically accosted which means you
can't apologize so you have to duel but
a good Christian never shoots directly
at his opponent so you should not shoot
at your opponent and so Philip listen to
this advice Hamilton thought that the
matter would end in negotiations and
actually I mean Philip being 19 very
often duels were called off because
someone was to just too young but in
fact the dual ended up being fought and
on the day of the duel Hamilton heard to
his horror he thought the duel was
happening he couldn't quite believe it
and he went to the home of the family
doctor who was present at every Hamilton
duel but he knew that if Philip was
going to the dueling ground he would
have got taken this doctor with him and
when he got to the doctor's house and
the doctor's wife answered the door and
said well yes actually Philip had been
there very early that morning and had
taken her husband with him Hamilton was
so stunned because it was clear that the
duel was happening that he literally
fainted on the doorstep of the house and
had to be carried in to the house and
when he regained consciousness
unfortunately was told that the not only
had the duel happened but his son had
been fatally wounded and I think he
lingered for a day but but died and it
just he never really quite recovered
from that and it actually Peas he was
using those same pistols in his 1804
duel with burr and actually Hamilton's
that they belonged to Hamilton's
brother-in-law amber had used them
before too cuz burr & Hamilton's
brother-in-law had dueled one so those
are the those pistols get around but um
clearly one thing that you can sort of
take from that incident is if nothing
else it's hard to imagine that given the
advice that Hamilton gave his son it's
hard to imagine that he then would have
gone and directly shot at burr because
he really was agonizing before the duel
about should he shoot or not at burr and
he finally decided no you know I'm not
going to shoot at him and clearly that
that earlier occasion had to influence
part of how he was thinking about that
did honor play as big of a role in
international politics for it one
thought I'm thinking is that you
mentioned Jefferson I'm thinking of the
Barbary pirates if that was a personal
affront to him or an affront to the
United States honor did it's a really
good question honor did play a role in
diplomatic relations that the challenge
was that not every country are not every
diplomat had the same sort of cultural
assumptions about what was or what
wasn't honorable and so actually a lot
of misunderstandings that happen are in
part that they're just cultural
misunderstandings that one side is doing
something that to them seems reasonable
honorable and fine and the other side is
horrified humiliated outraged to pick an
emotion but doesn't respond the same way
because in their mind that's not
honorable it's not proper and so
throughout this period some some
actually noteworthy sort of you know
diplomatic spats are partly over these
kinds of cultural complications now of
course Jefferson was very good at public
image and so he knew for example you
know that getting back to this idea of
being Republican and dressing like a
Republican when he was president he
really went out of his way to dress like
what he considered a Republican
president to be so not only did he wear
simple clothes but he were kind of
rundown clothes and he was known for
sort of shuffling around the White House
and in slippers were the back the heels
were worn off and apparently at some
point he received the British Minister
Anthony Mary in his rundown slippers and
of course Mary was like mortified and
humiliated and wrote back to Britain
that he'd been publicly humiliated by
Thomas Jefferson and this ended up yeah
I don't think Jefferson was actually too
sorry about this I think probably he
thought oh well fine he's gonna be that
way but but there's an example in which
I don't think he was deliberately trying
necessarily to insult the British
minister but you could understand why in
the you know compared with the rest of
the world which ever since doing would
seem to be you know entirely outrageous
and bizarre and thus insulting
great well there's no more questions
yeah I want to say thank you very much